instead we let these parasites live
among us the vile words and vitriol of a
neo-nazi Jack Renshaw was the baby-faced
spokesman of the far-right hate group
national action before it was officially
banned but preaching hate wasn't enough
for him in 2017 he bought a sword and
planned to murder his local MP Rosie
Cooper and a female police officer he
told associates at a pub in Warrington
that it would be an act of white jihad
concluding with him committing suicide
by cop the plot was only foiled because
one of them Robbie Mullen turned
Informer and he told she wants the tarts
wasn't he he looked up said yes he
looked sat at the same time so what was
wrong with her and then he told us about
his plan to kill his local MP we can now
report that Renshaw has also been
convicted of child sexual grooming
offering two teenage boys money for sex
it was the investigating officer in this
case he planned to kill Matthew Collins
was the first person Robbie Mullins
spoke to when he became a whistleblower
he told him Renshaw was determined and
dangerous probably Merlin hadn't have
made that call hadn't left a meeting and
made that call to us
rosie cooper MP was days away from being
murdered National Action targeted
students and used social media to spread
its vile it was officially banned as a
terrorist organisation in 2016 after it
openly glorified the man who murdered MP
Joe Cox a jury couldn't decide if
Renshaw and two others had subsequently
continued the group's work for the MP
Renshaw targeted the safety of public
figures is still a concern I think it's
awful that any public servant be a
teacher doctor nurse policeman MP should
be targeted and threatened with violence
simply because of the job they do the
prosecution said Renshaw and his
associates trained in this gym for what
they saw as the upcoming race war the
jury didn't agree but Renshaw's
murderous plot will never be enacted and
his day of glory
never come Helen Anne Smith Sky News